Ian's finances here we all know and love
Ian's finance from the podcast Sex in
the City and I was actually looking at
your Twitter yes and I saw a very
interesting text exchange uh-huh and it
was between you yes and somebody that
had gone to one of your great comedy
shows and the person that gone to your
comedy show was with their boyfriend yes
and they wanted to go out and have a
meal with you
Texas changer on Twitter he was an ad I
am DM okay am i animal for some DM fun
your DMS are wide open it was an
interesting DM exchange because the
couple I guess they just found
Ian to be affable and relatable and they
said we'd like to hang out them he's not
just for a staged relationship let's
bring him into our lives so Ian joking
but not joking haha
said that he was only interested in
meeting them for some food if they would
like to set up a threesome yes and it
seemed like it wasn't a very long text
exchange no but it went through waves it
seemed like they were like okay this is
gonna happen will she responded with
let's go where are you which is amazing
amazing and you're like I'm about to
have a threesome yes get some P and some
V yes yeah yeah yeah and some D dinner
yeah we went up to the apartment and
this guy was doing everything in his
power to stall lady just cuz he was
nervous
Holly like so they had a cat and you
know I love cats I went up I pet the cat
and he's like oh my god babe babe look
at the cat he likes the the cat likes
him like seeing more than you she never
likes anyone here pet her here I have a
toy do you want to see your cat tower
and I'm like okay and he goes I go oh
she is you know long nails he goes while
we clip the nails I'll clip the nails do
you want a frozen dessert I can make you
a Celt or do you want a seltzer
look at this paint like he's pointing
all these things out and she's like babe
babe babe stop and I go well why don't
you guys you guys can make out and I'll
just play with the cat and he's like
crazy yeah
like she's in Hawaii now you're in his
house and reality is station wheel this
is actually going to have yeah there's
got a mustache about to [ __ ] my wife I
just take my clothes off I leave my
boxers on cuz my dick is smaller than
it's ever been in my entire life I'm
like yeah I don't want this to be a good
first impression when the bull from this
scenario is packing one and a half I
must warn you I have tattoos all over my
body also my penis is inverted you know
so I took my ever everything off I love
my boxers on I just went up and I just
started like you know kissing her
nipples and you know kind of kissing her
body and she like really started liking
that and then I just started you know
playing with her [ __ ] and everything
and she was like really into me
fingering and everything and I noticed
she like really got off on me and not
him and that kind of made me feel better
of course I know I like that a lot
[Laughter]
came up later I was like you like this
strangers dick she responded in the
affirmative yes yeah yeah and then I
made her say that mine was better than
his I was like choker choker into the
bed he's Dulli as penis is soft a great
scenario you're wearing underpants
she had no gag reflex which was like
incredible you know it was really
amazing but she really like kind of
being you know roughed around a bit
which was like really nice and let me
ask you yes a little housing when he was
worst play when he was [ __ ] her yes
and she was blowing you mm-hmm
did she have to stop the oral because he
was [ __ ] her or did you just but when
you when the roles were reversed she had
to stop blowing him yes she took this
horrendous soft and yeah that's not good
for him no no I totally dominated
Scituate felt great didn't he ever
achieve climax no but here's the thing
when I was [ __ ] from behind I faked
an orgasm because I felt like I wasn't
gonna come so I faked it and you know
nobody coming here's the thing he's dead
he was like do you want that do you want
him to come in you do you want him gene
him to come in you that's the whole
thing calming me she's like call me a
slide I'm like you're all dirty okay so
he doesn't want a threesome he wants to
be cocked tonight he wants his wife to
be bred yeah